first thing is get over it every
decision in the world this is a very
subtle point that seems obvious but most
people miss every decision in the world
is made by the person has a power to
make that decision make peace for that
not the best person or the smartest
person or the prettiest person or the
brightest person every decision is made
by the person who has a power to make
the decision if you got laid off right
someone who had the power decision got
rid of you that wasn't your decision it
was theirs
well guess what somebody else sold
themselves to that person better than
you did make peace it happens what do
you do move on with your life say okay
where can I go from here don't cut off
your nose to spite your face attacking
the boss in front of the next employer
is idiotic because that next employer if
you attack the boss is going to think
what do you say about me when I'm not
around that's idiotic
the people out there know the market is
what it is they know hard times are what
they are you don't have to rationalize
or make excuses just say I worked there
here's what happened here's where I am
here's how I can make a contribution to
the future and your job is to sell my
next advice to that person is get real
offers one of the big mistakes people
make when they're in career transition
is I say well maybe I want to do X or
maybe I do y they get into these mental
gymnastics don't do that you got to get
real offers there is no X or Y until you
get real offers and real offers are good
you can always say no you don't have
take it but you can't say no to an offer
you don't have so my advice to all my
clients going through transition is get
real alternatives get real offers and
you might be surprised what you end up
liking and if you say no it's okay you
probably learned something in the
process anyway don't go out though and
just jerk around and sit there and say
well maybe this is interesting maybe it
isn't maybe I'd like that maybe I
wouldn't you end up with nothing then